the holiday shopping season is in full
swing with exactly two weeks until
Christmas two weeks
yikes the National Retail Federation
says we are expected to spend more than
700 billion dollars for the 12th year in
a row
gift cards remain the most popular items
on wishlist but a new warning from the
Better Business Bureau says criminals
are wiping those gift cards clean before
you even have a chance to use them
Charisse Jones is USA TODAY's national
business correspondent she's back she
joins us with how the scam works and
what you can do to protect yourself hey
Charisse Jones hello so I'm thinking a
gift Cort I always think that's an easy
way out for people
I'll just give you a gift card but
you're saying it's a good idea but it's
a good idea but you've got to be careful
for the criminals that are kind of
lurking in the aisle what are they doing
standby the kiosk yeah and they take the
gift card they write down the number and
the pin and they put it back then you
purchase it they see you've done it they
go quickly online and they basically use
up the balance on the gift card so
you've got to be slicker than they are
people are actually doing that on a
regular basis yes I mean because it's a
popular gift it's easy to snatch so they
go to the back of the rack you get the
card from there because usually they're
taking the cards from the phone
yeah you know so you pick them up check
the packaging to make sure that it's not
been disrupted make sure the pins not
exposed if it is put it back or tell the
employee and get another card and
sometimes you can register the card so
if the balance is compromised you can
still get your money back and the reason
they can't just strip off the code is
because it doesn't get activated until
somebody actually buys it is that right
and that's why they're kind of waiting
and they want to see you actually buy
the card then they can go right to their
iPad and start purchasing another big
issue is not just gift cards but this is
the season of the year where a lot of
temporary jobs are created and companies
are hiring people just for these few
months but there are scam artists there
as well tell us that's kind of
surprising that you would do that to
somebody who's looking for work but
obviously during the holiday season a
lot of folks want that part-time gig and
you're you know really anxious to get it
so you might give up your social
security number on that site you know
for the employer you do that now you've
been exposed so the best thing to do was
to actually go to the company's website
and look at the job listings or go to
the local store yourself and apply for
the job in person so that you don't get
compromised
it online is it a good rule of thumb
just never give your social security
number online under any circumstances
right you should never do that people
get desperate you know they're looking
for work and they think well they want
to look in my background you know they
might you know they're gonna pay me
they're gonna need that number anyway
and they're not thinking and they get
careless so you've got to be very
careful so a lot of a shop on Amazon or
Walmart and they sell a lot of
third-party products that's right I know
that the US Government Accountability
Office is looking into whether this
raises the risk of essentially getting a
fake product online what happens if you
get a product that's not good quality if
you get something in the logo looks
funny or you know that it's probably
fake you can go to the vendor or go to
Walmart and Amazon and ask for a refund
you can go to your credit card company
and cancel the purchase and if it gets
down to it you can go to your local
Better Business Bureau or a government
consumer person and say I've been
scammed there's selling counterfeit
merchandise yeah I feel like Amazon's
usually pretty good yeah yeah thank you
sure injuries Jones thanks so much for
keeping us safe around the holidays and
we'll be right back in a moment